hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round seven of the 2019
us championship we already mentioned in
the previous video regarding this
championship that Nakamura is in the
lead but we haven't seen well even one
game from Nakamura so far so I decided
to show this guy this one it was played
yesterday and it's it's quite a matchup
Nakamura is some 100 and 120 points
higher rated than a Cobian but also you
know in their previous encounters they
played Nakamura won seven games Akopian
won only one game and five games were
drawn and the only game Akopian ever won
against Nakamura was 17 years ago back
in 2002 I was at the first game they
ever played so you know it wouldn't be
all that bad for a Cobian to win this
one with the white pieces so let's see
what happens without further adue
equipment has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have d6 that by
Nakamura perhaps asking is maybe akka
been interested in transposing into the
pitch defense but he isn't he was Knight
to f3
we have g6 by Nakamura c4 and now Bishop
to g7 we have nice the c3 Knight to c6
and now d5 grabbing more space in the
center Knights the e5 by Nakamura and
now Knight captures Bishop captures and
E for now so wide created this a very
impressive Center and black of course as
he did think at the dark square bishop
will have a very strong dark square
Bishop Knight to f6 now the knight
blocks the bishops retreat to g7 but it
doesn't matter White has no way of
taking advantage of it for example if
you play F capture
F for black and always capture on c3
remove the defender of d4 pawn and then
white even loses the point so there's no
way to take advantage of this so weird
position of the bishop on on e5 Bishop
to d3 by white and now we have castles
by black and again f4 doesn't do
anything now even though you're
protecting d4 pawn twice because Bishop
b4 and now you're preventing castle you
can go back to b6 and also because the
bishop is on d3 the Queen can no longer
capture the bishop on d4 so after this
castle
have castles Byakko beyond as well east
6 minor camera going after white strong
center h3 and now he captures on d5 and
here we had a game in 2016 in the
European blitz championship we're at
sweetened plate he captures on d5
against Tony shook and the only ship won
that game but here we have see captors
on d5 and ok now it's it's a different
game we're nice to h5 by Nakamura hoping
to go to this very nice f4 square and
white of course prevents it we have f4
Bishop to d4 check King to h2 and now
Queen to h4 already Nakamura species are
piling up in front of whites King and
you have to be very careful if white
makes a slow move let's say some silly
move then the thread is Queen g3 check
and the ones that came moves just Bishop
captures on h3 and white falls apart in
a you know in various ways the most
obvious one of course pawn captures and
Queen captures with checkmate as the
bishop controls this diagonal so after
Queen to h4 equipment decides Queen to
e1 he wants to trade Queens he doesn't
know how queen g3 and nakamura decides
this is favorable for him we have Queen
capture sunny one rook captures anyone
and now a Nakamura takes this
opportunity to remain over the bishop to
a much nicer square but Row 2 f2 with an
attack against the rook rook to f1 and
now butter up the g3 check with pressure
against the f4 pawn the King has to move
and now comes f5 and here you cannot
push a 5 it'd be great if you could but
you can because the bishop the pawn
controls it but also the bishop controls
the e5 square so that's the problem but
not h1 the king wants the g1 not h1
sorry about that
now we have f5 as well as mentioned and
now rook to f3 by white and here what do
you play here it's a very interesting
position you know try to get a feel of
the position and imagine you're playing
black how do you continue this position
I'll give you it's not like a puzzle to
solve is just to find the correct way to
continue and
feel free to pause the video while doing
so I'll give you a couple of seconds to
decide whether we want to do it or not
if you were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of plants and for those of you
who just want to enjoy show if you found
pawn captures immediately on e4 then
white will get a very nice expansion for
this for example Knight captures with a
double attack against the bishop the
bishop moves now g3 comes and white has
a very nice position if you continue
this way with the black pieces
what Nakamura played is before he played
Bishop captures on f4 seemingly a
temporary pawn sacrifice a piece
sacrifice which occupy on accepts and
only now pawn captures and now Nakamura
can go into some very favourable
exchanges for him so you do have to
capture the pawn Bishop captures was
played in only not Knight captures on f4
recapturing the piece rook eight f1y
doubles up on the F file and now g5 just
defending you can't do any damage by
going g3 white can just go night-night
g6 for example and the rockin f8 will be
protected so we have h4 by white and now
Bishop to g4 a very important in between
move that forces the rook to move and
also now black has connected rooks we
have rook to g3 attacking the bishop and
now h5 and here white wants the went
back the pawn and to do so he must
double his pawn so here H captures on g5
and now rook e8 e8
so the material on the board is equal
but as you can see white has three point
islands where black has only two point
islands and the white has a double DG
pawn so this is what the Nakamura has to
show for for his impressive play with
did the black pieces we have Bishop to
f3 offering a trade and Nakamura doesn't
mind he simply improves the position of
the rook going after the weak d5 pawn
there's no way to increase it as the
bishop will be traded off with Bishop
captures pawn captures rook captures and
now comes Knight captures on d5 just
grabbing that pawn Knight captures on d5
and now and Nakamura trades everything
off rook captures King captures and rook
captures on d5 so here we have a
position where Nakamura
well we could say for to to advantage on
the queenside
and well white has to 2-0 advantage and
the King said but it's a GG pawn easy
prey for for Nakamura's rook so white
continues to the improve the position of
the King we have King - E - black does
the same King g7 rook the c-4 attacking
the c7 point Nakamura just the defends
it it's a much simpler position to play
with the black pieces but you know when
you're a strong Grandmaster you you know
end up in a better endgame rook to e4 by
YT going after the seventh ranked King
to g6 now going after the g5 pawn and
there's no way to defend it I mean if
you do something silly the sorry the
King and pawn and game will always be
winning for black after let's say King
f3
you can go d5 and then the the passed
pawn will always be winning
so after king g6 we looked at east 7 and
now comes Luke the b5 going after the B
to pawn but also defending the b7 pawn
we have b3 by white defending the beat
upon and now just King captures on g5 we
look to d7 going after the d6 pawn but
now just d5 and Nakamura now has a very
strong passed pawn it will be very very
hard to prevent this kink the d3 by
white we have kink to f6 king to c3 and
now comes a 5 we look to c7 just you
know keeping everything in order
pressuring the pawns but King to e6 we
have a three by white and now again what
what do you think the best idea here
from black is once again feel free to
pause the video and try to find just a
very nice maneuver that Nakamura found I
hope you didn't have to pause the video
for long but if you were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and for those of you who
just won't enjoy the show the idea is d4
with check you just want to get that
King away from the defense of the b3
pawn and then you can just gobble up all
of the points there here of course he
decided not
accurate equipment plays Quinta c4 we
have d3 no Nakamura still wants to get
rid of the spawn and the King prevents
the rope from joining the hunt for a for
the d3 pawn king back to c3 and now d2
and now white does have to you know lose
control of the b3 pawn king capture some
d2 was played Nakamura capture some b3
we have G for white starts pushing the
passport but Nakamura just goes a 4 with
g5 and now first King to d6 defending
the c6 pawn while preparing b5 we look
to f7 hoping to from you know escort his
passport all the way now comes b5 by
Nakamura all of the pawns are now
protected g6 and here just rook captures
on a3 here I could even play pawn to g7
Nakamura just went rook to g3 and it was
in this position that evolution aku
beyond resigned to the game on move 47
as there is nothing more to do here
you can never move the rook to the final
rank as you will lose this pawn if you
just promote the pond and a rook will
just gobble it up and black has you know
all the time in the world to just push
all of the pawns I improve the position
of the king do whatever and win the game
easily just well it seemed like like a
super easy win for Nakamura and if you
go through the game once again it will
be very hard to pinpoint where did the
white go wrong and Nakamura was just
able to trade off in a favorable endgame
and he was able to win this favorable
endgame so that's that's what it is
chess is a struggle and even if you
don't make any serious blunder or a
serious mistake you know just slowly and
slowly if your opponent is able to
improve his position and you're not able
to keep up then at some point you know
the position just crumbles so yeah
that's that's what happened here an
excellent victory for Nakamura with the
black pieces and with this victory he
retains his lead in the u.s.
championship there you have it we have a
nice cross table from chess 24 website I
will also put a link to it in the
description below if you want to check
it out there Nakamura now in first place
with 5 points then with 4 and a half
points
Fabiana Caruana who won a crazy ending
against Timor Guerrero yesterday then
linear Dominguez Paris and Samuel seven
would four and have done with four
Wesley so with three and a half
Jeffrey's young and then we have with
three points a lot of people
Aleksandra Linda and Samuel Shanklin
last year is the winner ray Robson in
the Wonderland and which two points
Veronica be on with this loss against
Nakamura and Timur Karev yeah there we
have it
I do hope you enjoy that and that you
are enjoying this short coverage of the
US Championship I would very much like
the like the here ah Cubans opinion if
he will maybe be doing a video on this
game or I've seen Nakamura the covers
his game against Caruana
on his channel so maybe he'll also cover
this game I would be I would be very
interested to see how how he you know
his thought process throughout this game
maybe maybe he'll do it so we can enjoy
that as well
everybody I will see I would like to
thank a shish Kumar then his fat land
also hoodie guy on Leach s if you want
to challenge him
Rohan Pulido no dubravka yoga and
Nicolas Richmond for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content the today's video came a little
bit earlier but it's because I might do
a second one today we'll see how it goes
thank you and I will see you soon